hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow midseason finale video we
got everything this week we have bondage
we have awesome villains we have other
people wearing Oliver's costume so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet don't you just love how
they kind of did a twist on what they
did with the Oliver Queen death last
season and let's be honest raise your
hand who thinks the felicity is dead
write down or she is dying honestly I
don't think that the show is gonna kill
off such a big character this earlier in
the season whenever they flash-forward
to that grave at the beginning of the
season they were flashing forward six
months that puts it at the full season
finale episode 23 so we're not even
halfway to whoever ends up in that grave
dying so just based on this past episode
definitely not gonna be felicity now
that doesn't mean that she's not gonna
die at some point that just means that
this episode is not indicating who's
ending up in the grave just a quick
reminder though the reverse flash ring
giveaway is still going on all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video real simple so
here we go top 5 WTF number 5 damian
darhk-- straigth Oliver's cleaning of
the bay with a bunch of schoolchildren
Oliver gets to save a mini Felicity
almost in the exact same way that he
saves Felicity at the beginning of
season 2 I think it was I think that
time he was swinging on a vine but like
he tackles Felicity to save her from
this trap tackles mini Felicity who's
also pretty adorable herself to I'm sure
someday that little girl is gonna have
some super duper crush on me Oliver
Queen that's the guy that saved me and
it wasn't even as Green Arrow Oliver
Queen was doing this in public in the
light of day
that's kind of a big theme this season
Oliver stepping out into the light I
mean it's the holidays right now so
they're doing holiday Lighting's but you
know matically stepping out into the
light because damian darhk-- is part of
the darkness flash and arrows pun game
has been really strong this week that's
actually good game to play after you
watch the episode one time go back and
watch it again and see if you can spot
all of the puns from flash and arrow
this week on a my number four WTF though
Diggle versus his brother he's trying so
hard to help his brother Andy but Andy
just is not having it you don't know the
real me I mean right now I don't think
we really have a good sense for what's
going on in Andy's head he's not
brainwashed anymore he's not on the
chemicals the damian darhk-- hands out
to people maybe he's fully drunk in the
kool-aid so you can actually add him to
the list of people that might end up in
that grave I mean I think Diggle or
Quentin would be a bigger W
yes because they'd be like a core team
arrow person but Andy dying would also
be really emotional for team arrow just
because they're so close to Diggle on a
my number three WTF all of like the
relationship comedy so in one lane you
have Oliver and Felicity like the the
whole comedy about the ring Felicity
finding it her mom freaking out then in
the other Lane you have Felicity's mom
in Quentin which is actually way funnier
for me seriously don't tell Laurel she
doesn't know yet
Felicity's just throwing up in her mouth
but the whole deal with Felicity in the
ring with Oliver they made it very easy
to follow Felicity just doesn't want
Oliver to take the choice of choosing to
marry him away from her like Oliver has
this big deal where he tries to protect
everyone so he takes a lot of choice
away from people like he chooses for
them she made the joke last week that
Oliver was back in secret-keeping mode
now that was about his secret son which
he still hasn't told this version of
Felicity in this timeline yet but
Felicity just like seriously if you
would have asked I would have said yes I
chose this life I get to choose who
protects me it's the don't treat me like
a damsel in distress speech the problem
with that is that even though she's
gung-ho about this there are
consequences it's easy to say don't
protect me I can take care of myself
until you get bit by a shark like
flashback Oliver on my number two WTF
Merlyn to the rescue he was on fire this
week seriously this lair is easier to
break into than your last one he just
appears out of nowhere he's kind of a
magical character even though he's not
using magic and I love the fact that
they let him wear the green arrow
costume that's kind of a running thing
on arrow with other people getting to
where Oliver's costume Roy's worn
Oliver's costume diggle's worn Oliver's
costume I'd say they'd let the canary
and Thea wear the costume but I think
that they're too short usually the other
people that we're all overs costume kind
of resemble him physically like they're
almost the exact same size that's why I
could do it that's why Merlyn can do it
because they're about the same size but
there was a brief moment when he was
fighting damian darhk-- that I was like
ooh maybe Merlin's gonna be the one that
dies now John Barrowman is an amazing
actor so I think it would really suck if
the show lost him but he did explain in
this episode like I mean he's still have
a big part of this League of Assassins
storyline the reason he didn't use them
is because he doesn't want open war
between the league and hide because hive
is a way bigger organization than
they've lent on during arrow episodes so
as badasses the
League of Assassins are you can't blame
Merlin for wanting to keep them out of
it but he does want to protect Thea so
of course he's gonna throw himself in
what about the Genesis project though
damian darhk-- kind of does this
demonstration it just seems like
knockout gas but what I think it's gonna
be is like a low level version of what
he's giving to the ghosts like turn
everyone into worker bees as in hive so
bad news is probably has absolutely
nothing to do with New Genesis or
Apocalypse or New Gods
I know we thought this might be a mother
box a couple episodes ago probably not
arrows probably going a little bit more
realistic albeit with some magic thrown
in the funny thing about this is is that
damien darhk's plan seems like it has
absolutely nothing to do with magic this
is hives plan some of the other members
of hive think of him as like a charlatan
they actually said that in an earlier
episode so it sounded like the rest of
hive doesn't really know what's going on
with damien darhk's magic but of course
on a my number one WTF what are you
gonna do about Oliver Queen cut to limo
assassination attempt just the way they
cut the episode from scene to scene like
it went from the lighting ceremony to
damian darhk-- back to oliver in the
limo with felicity
you knew exactly what was gonna happen
the question is though is what's gonna
happen to felicity now obviously
Oliver's gonna be pissed but felicity in
the teaser for the next episodes being
willed into critical care so I
definitely don't think she's gonna die
but I think it's intended to push Oliver
in a darker direction like how you know
how dare you come after the person that
I love in this way how dare you try to
kill us so here's my question for you
guys let me know in the comments what do
you think is gonna happen with damien
darhk's plan do you think he's just
going to try and disseminate this
biological agent just you know take over
the entire city it seems like they're
just contained to this one city for now
star city but what about Oliver what do
you think that Oliver is going to do to
retaliate I know there is a whole bunch
of other stuff that they've announced
for the second half of the season
they're bringing Felicity's father on
they've already announced that he's
going to be the calculator the episode
that he is coming in will also be the
episode that Colton comes back for the
tease that they released is that the
calculator is using Roy to enact plans
like he's blackmailing Roy into
committing crimes for him so team arrow
obviously all have to save Roy and take
down calculator the actor that they cast
is one of the dads from Everwood if you
haven't seen that show in a long time it
was Greg Berlanti he's like first big TV
show obviously now he's like this giant
Titan of TV but way way back
he had a TV show with star-lord in agent
13 so oh no I feel like this was a good
episode it was a very different type of
episode like the tone was very different
from the flash or even agents of shield
or some of the other mid-season finales
from the comic book TV shows I feel like
it was a good episode for people that
really hate Felicity's character because
you're like oh yeah yeah they definitely
took her down or if you're really into
the relationship comedy stuff because
there was a lot of that in this episode
but I have to say Neal McDonough the
actor the plays damian darhk-- is doing
an amazing job way better as a big bad
then zoom is right now technically zoom
is the big bat of the flash even though
Harrison wells seems like an antagonist
but that's just you another good
question let me know in the comments who
do you think has like the best villain
performance so far Neal McDonough
playing arrow or Tony Todd playing the
zoom character because you know like
zoom does have more power like he's more
powerful he has the speed he has special
abilities that may or may not be more
powerful than damien darhk's magic we
really don't have any idea if there's no
basis for comparison on that but I feel
like they're very different types of
villains so it's kind of apples and
origins I feel like they're both amazing
like Tony Todd is amazing as the voice
of zoom just completely terrifying still
so many question marks and Nia McDonald
just wipes the floor with all the other
actors whenever he shares scenes with
them great holiday episode though
everybody be sure to high-five Quentin
on your way out forgetting a little some
seriously how long has it been since
he's been on a date
maybe after he and River Song broke up
who actually got a shout-out during the
flash episode they said that Laurel was
in Central City visiting her mother so
what's gonna happen is is there are a
couple trailers for the rest of the
season I'll at least try to get a flash
one ah I don't know if I'll have time to
do an arrow one two but I'll definitely
try to do an air video sometime later
this week there's a new Doctor Strange
video that I have there's new Star Wars
and there's new Captain America Civil
War video so I'll try to get that out as
fast as possible waiting is wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for last night's episode of the flash if
you haven't
yet anything click here for my Batman vs
Superman trailer video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight